alright let's talk about exercise
optimization formula ok now I'm going to
give you kind of a general guideline and
then we'll get more specific here's some
basic things you must know all the
benefit of exercise of exercising
stressing your body spending time then
recovering is in the recovery so the
benefit of exercise is in the recovery
after the exercise exercise in itself
actually just stresses and breaks your
body down but the benefit is your
ability to recover and burn fat so when
it's recovering its burning fat
many people do not give enough time in
the recovery phase of exercise to be
able to see the change I was in basic
training for Jackson South Carolina 1983
I went in their top shape going the
state to wrestle you know the whole
thing I was in really good shape a
wrestler by the time I graduated after
three months I could barely pass the PT
test could do it couldn't even do a
push-up couldn't even run why because of
no recovery they didn't let me sleep
it was exercise every day there was no
downtime it destroyed my body and also
stress so with exercise you will lose
way more weight with the eating part
then you will with the exercise some
people say well I'm gonna eat what I
want I'm just gonna exercise twice as
hard oh really how does that working for
you it's not going to work so the eating
is most important I have helped a lot of
people lose weight by stopping working
out but I'm not against working out we
need to do it but we have to make sure
your sleep is good if your sleep is good
then you can do more exercise I'm not
saying it's not exercise I want you to
keep doing exercise but I want to make
sure you recover from it so here's
here's what happens if you're sleeping
and you're exercising and you're not
getting sore and you feel pretty good
the next day or every third day then you
can go ahead and keep doing what you're
doing and we'll plug in the other stuff
but I want to give you some other things
to think with so it's not so a cookbook
if you're working out and you don't feel
good after you
work out then you're overtraining
overtraining is very dangerous to the
heart I have a machine that measures
people and I find people sometimes we're
at risk for heart attacks and they don't
even know it okay so give your body a
chance to recover when you're doing like
an hour of kickboxing or Zumba or some
hardcore workout it's much better to do
that every third day then every day or
even every other day especially as you
get older especially with weight loss
some people I find you have to do it
once every week or twice a week that
would be the optimum time because they
have to give themselves downtown
downtime and on the downtime they can go
for long walks they can do yoga they can
do stretching that type of thing Pilates
is great yoga is great but for the
adrenal body type we want to kind of err
on the smaller amount of exercise okay
but as soon as you start sleeping you
feeling better now we can really pick up
the pace and start to just do some crazy
hardcore workouts but there is a little
formula I'm going to teach you that will
give you the data on how where you are
at at risk for your heart okay like you
want to know if you want to risk for a
heart attack that you can do this what
you do is you you need a stopwatch and
you need something to check your pulse
rate you can have a pulse rate a meter
that they'll check they you can put it
on your finger and check your pulse rate
or you just take your two fingers and
press on the artery and feel your pulse
rate or your artery right here and feel
the pulse rate and you can count it I
like to count it for 15 seconds and then
multiply it times four to get the total
minute of number of pulse beats a normal
pulse beat for each minute should be
like 72 okay if it's lower that could be
very good unless you don't workout then
it could be very bad but we want it kind
of lower than that we want it like 16 18
and 50 especially for athletes so we get
the resting pulse rate before you
exercise then you get on some type of I
don't know a machine or in place you can
do burpees you can do run in place you
can do jump rope you can do something to
get your whole body under some intense
exercise for one minute okay so we've
got the right right down the resting
pulse rate we do this incredible
look out we spiked the pulse rate and
then we measure our pulse rate again
okay when we spiked it let's pretend
that goes to 150 after 1 minute workout
then we're going to rest for one minute
and recheck the pulse rate so let's say
we rest for one minute and the pulse
rate reduces down to 140 so we subtract
150 for 140 and that equals 10 okay if
your if we measure 12 or pulse repeats
or less in other words if you spike your
pulse rate and it only comes down 12 or
less than that you are at risk for heart
attacks you should not be exercising
right now you can do some slight walking
in a flat surface but your heart cannot
handle that because it's not recovering
very dangerous but if your pulse rate
comes down fast let's see it goes down
by 50 points you are in good shape you
can handle a workout so really this
indicator of how fast your pulse rate
recovers after the first minute is a
real good clue to see how healthy you
really are okay it's one of the best
indicators of health especially for the
heart what we want is a fast recovery
like of course when you're 18 you can
recover fast but then what you do is you
recheck you keep checking your pulse
rate every minute and see how long it
takes for it to come all the way down to
the resting pulse rate okay let's say it
takes five minutes to go down then if
you were going to do interval training
which is a type of high-intensity rest
you would do it for one minute of
exercise and you would wait for five
minutes of rest that would be your
pattern so we exercise for one minute of
intensity and we rest for five minutes
we exercise one minute rest for five
minutes and we do like three cycles of
that to start out with because the
ratios of interval training of a short
burst of exercise and lots of rest this
is a way to figure it out what we don't
want to do is do one minute on and one
minute off one minute on one minute off
no no that's not that's not enough time
to recover because when you spike your
pulse rate and then we wait for it to
come back and then we do it again and do
it again
we're not strengthening our recovery
systems
you're just overdoing it you're putting
your body and overwhelm so you can watch
this video again and can take notes but
the point is that we want to spike the
pulse rate see how fast it comes down to
determine our interval training but also
determine if you're at risk so if you're
between 20 and 30 that's pretty much
okay if you're greater than 30 or more
you're actually in really good shape and
you can recover very well all right so
that's exercise optimization formula